what's interesting is that um
you know the market in las vegas has
been so hot since early 2019 and the
median price of homes has gone up so
much that where we are starting to see a
lot of interest is in like
more affordable areas so in the list
that was sent um the themes i would call
out is kind of just west and just east
of down of the strip it's getting a lot
of interest because those are
traditionally areas that have been more
affordable and so when a lot more of the
suburban areas have gone up in price by
so much i think people are now
gravitating towards value and i think
that's only going to accelerate um as
federal interest rates come up um and
then the other theme that i thought was
interesting
was there's a many zips in that list um
where
that are there are like very far
suburban so um you know southwest las
vegas out near enterprise um
getting like very far northwest las
vegas near like thule and then you know
going out farther east towards sunrise
manor um those are all areas where the
farther out you go you tend to be able
to get a little more value for your
money so what open door offers is really
a fast and certain transaction and that
um has appeal to a lot of sellers so
for many people they don't want to have
to stage their home
you know accommodate any number of tours
and open houses and i think that was
only accelerated by covid with fears
around the pandemic and
interacting with people um open door was
able to provide a fully virtual
experience
where we could give a very strong offer
without ever having to enter the home
via virtual tours and various images and
video
so many of the sellers that we work with
are just delighted by the experience